thank you God
thank you God now I have to think
it's incredible
such a great honor to receive this first
of all I just want to say hello to my
mother I want to dedicate this to my
grandmother who has been in my ear my
entire life telling me I could do
anything I put my mind to
I want to thank my daughter
for telling me just before I got up here
if you don't win dad you're still good
this is an Oscar a vision for courage
and for peace this is for everyone who
feels like they don't belong you are
unconditionally loved
for the uniqueness that is you
you don't let anybody tell you you are
ever past your Prime
their greater men and women than I but
thank you so much to the women in this
category he were all so extraordinary
and I can't deny the fact that you like
me if you're lucky enough to have a
parent or two alive on this planet
call them
God I know we're forgetting something
whoever we forgot we love you and we
love you thank you thank you so much it
doesn't matter how you get knocked down
in life because that's gonna happen
all that matters is that you got to get
up
thank you so much for this